less than a year after Thailand's newest
opposition party had a surprise showing
in elections winning the third most
seats in parliament the Constitutional
Court Friday dissolved the future
forward party saying it had taken an
illegal donation from its billionaire
leader the party denied this saying it
was a lone leader tunnel torn June roon
ranked it and 15 other party executives
are banned from politics for 10 years 65
members of parliament who won their
seats with future forward will have to
join another party or form their own we
spoke with Donna torn about the ruling
and the future so future forward as a
entity cease to exist it's dead no more
however the soul continues the journey
continues future Ford will now become a
social movement he says but it will
continue at all costs no one wants to go
to jail
right but somebody has to do this
somebody has to do it and the if that
means we have to confront with the
Boonta you know you have to do it
otherwise you can bring you cannot bring
about change
another challenge will be how to
convince the establishment as a whole
you know the two Kunda is just part of
this establishment how to communicate to
them how to convince them that it's time
to let go of the power before any
bloodshed you know some feel that
continued repression of those who speak
out against the centers of power
something that future-forward was trying
to do inside the Parliament will lead to
further discontent and that's something
that could evolve into unrest there be a
buildup accumulation of grievances the
economy economies mismanage Thai society
is deeply disenchanted political
authoritarianism is more rampant and
therefore a kind of showdown people want
to take back their country they want to
have their own future Thailand has a
history of showdowns like that after
this ruling there are more than 6
million voters who wanted future forward
to lead that charge inside the system
but
now they might be looking for ways to
get it done outside on the streets
Scott hilar al Jazeera Bangkok